yeah thank you very much um I I'd like
to start with a kind of a question
because uh as I said I didn't really
prepar something and uh this will be a
live coding session and so I'd like to
know what what you're interested in and
I show you two projects of mine um who
we can write test for right now um one
is a note project is that that's a
helper for writing better commit
messages um you see I sneak in some
parts of my part of my talk that has
been
rejected um I show you how that works so
I have a project here
that's um and I add I'm commit is this
big enough can you read
this okay for the whole talk if you have
anything uh any ideas anything how to
make this thing better if I should talk
slower or you just want to say something
or see an error I do just yell at me and
uh feel free to to interrupt that would
be
nice so I add the package Jason
here
and um there's a tool called
committed and I can say get SE
set and now he he is um proposing types
for for this commit so um the package
Json is probably sh commit and that's on
the package and now I can write
something
here I don't uh yeah I don't
know
basically uh the not package is a a
small tool that can help um that's part
of this chain to write better commit
messages so and that um that's untested
right now and we could write notes unit
test for that
tool the other thing is um I work at jyo
and we do have this um UI
Library
it looks like this um it's basically a
long list of oh I can scroll somehow so
a long list of patterns um that we can
use in our um
uis
and I don't know if there is that's not
really a use case but in lack of a
better project to test we could write
some uh ENT to end test for this Library
so
basically we can switch from production
to
better um State and
see Marcus for
example and um yeah we can basically use
selenium to click on that and maybe make
some
screenshots um so that's these are the
two projects I I I'd propose and now by
a sign of hand who would like to see um
unit test for for note project
okay and enter end test for for
another okay we do enter end
test I can close
this I reset this
commit
so um I won't go into the details of
setting up this stuff because uh I
use um not that fancy new technology um
I will use night watch which is kind of
a yeah and not a hipstar just new
project that came up but some some good
software
that in my opinion uh is is stable and
um I won't be really opinionated about
what to use for for that stuff but
instead I I'd like to um show you the
concepts that um I think you can uh
apply on other Frameworks like
protractor or uh some new newer stuff so
I worked a lot with protractor for
angular apps and um as you might heard
all angular apps are now dying and we
ski to re act and stuff so um protractor
is not that really a
thing so let's go to
nightwatch I prepared uh what I did is I
installed Night Watch npm install night
watch you can get it and I installed a
selenium helper that
is called Web driver
manager and that can help me to uh set
up a selenium server
locally here we go selenium server is up
and running so what we now can do
is start the demo
app
I think I killed the server
so yeah that might take a little
while and
then i' watch is testing
something
I'm not really sure but because the
screen is so small um maybe we can we
will run into issues because of that
um but we will
see no actually okay my first test I I
prepared is passing so everything is
fine here's what I did um we
have uh Night Watch Jason
oh that's a wrong project one moment me
take this
one here's a nightwatch Jason uh
basically this is uh just cargo cting
from the
nightwatch
homepage interesting is that we uh
connect to our selenium
here so we started a selenium
server and that's running on my local
machine here on Port 4444
and here we are saying Night Watch to
connect to this that could be um also
some um Cloud servers like Source Labs
or BR deck or something um anything that
can uh that provides a selenium uh
API and uh we are saying hey we want to
use a chrome and the rest of this file
is pretty much just uh C cting set
up here's my first test so basically
what we're doing is U we're recycling
the browser to way more than this CA can
um show us so maybe 600 to 800 or 800
600 then we want to test something so
let's test
um the product
tag what we first need to do we tell the
client to go on this website so that's
exactly the one that I showed you here
it's running on my local machine could
be anywhere I could run this test
against a production um side I could
could run it against Google or
whatever and then I'm uh just asserting
that there is an element with this CSS
selector on the page um it's a UI
tag that's active and I want to uh
ensure that this is production so
basically would this would be a test to
ensure that we see this state when we
land on this
page it could be that
some person thinks it would good would
be good to to have the beta enabled by
default and then this Tech uh this test
would fail so if we say we would like to
have the beta enabled by default and run
the test
again you can watch it here
yeah and now it says hey
um the element with this selector
contains the text beta um um that was
our assertion but we got production so
something
is wrong
um you go but uh we actually want to
have it to be
production and now let's change that
let's say hey um what happens if we do
this we land on the
page we click this button and we click
this button now we want to have want to
sure that the beta button is a
active it's simple as that we say
click
here now we should have a state where uh
where there's
no active
tag and then we click on the
other
check button I'm searching for a
selector that we can actually click on
um new itch beta looks
promising
whoops and now we assert that this is
bet in case you wonder I have a PA here
just to have a chance to see the state
before uh the browser quits uh if we
would run that NCI or some um headless
brow this is pretty much useless so we
can skip that but right now it uh it's
kind of interesting to see the state
that we
are after uh having manual manually
click
um not manually
clicked I rerun
this and that
work so these are our two assertions and
we have production better and everything
is
fine I think you GA the idea um you can
basically uh go crazy with this and we
could
uh yeah normally on the left side here
would be a navigation we could check if
the navigation works so that we see the
exact pattern that we navigated to we
can uh check the context switch that we
have here but I think that would be
repetitive um so let's dig a little bit
into uh regression um visual regression
stuff what we just recently did is to uh
use exactly this tool to um do then
screenshots of this page so what we can
do is um say
hey
[Music]
please
screenshot
here um and I think I have to let save
screenshot and I have to
say
beta
St or something like that I don't
actually know if this works let's
check doesn't look like it um so
the oh here here it is nice we have a
screenshot
so and
um we could now uh take this screenshot
and run some
uh image analysis against it and compare
it with another screenshot that we made
made few years ago and say hey we want
to have uh want to ensure that there's
no difference between this and that um
the there are tools that do all that out
of the box like um Phantom CSS and web
driver IO um problem is right now I feel
that both of these projects are kind of
in a in a not that stable state so
that's why we uh
used night watch but I highly recommend
to um to check for for Pro for projects
that do all that out of the box before
you um try try to to make come up with
some
solution for your own
um so what's the
time that was just uh minutes 50 minutes
okay what we do
now any
ideas question yeah
you actions in your app so how do you
know when your app is ready
that's a really good question
um I kind of hope that we just came into
a situation where that uh happened and
then I forgot about that thing
so there are asynchronous things so
maybe the web page will um load some
scripts after user clicked on a specific
button or um maybe you have a really big
Javascript app that just takes some time
to calculate a state or whatever
um one thing I really loved about
protractor is that protractor can hook
into angular and kind of asks angular if
there is a state that um that is stable
so you can if you know um a little bit
of insight of angular angular has this
digest Loops so basically whenever I
click on a button angular just runs and
uh and waits for a state where there's
no change and um with
protractor these uh angular can tell hey
I have a state where where I don't
expect any changes and now you can make
assertions um so in basically if you
happen to work on an angular app I
highly recommend to use protector but
because you normally don't need to think
about that um but let's just assume
we're on not on on an angular app and we
have some asynchronous stuff
here so as as you see when I reload that
page um I maybe can throttle that a
bit there's is this loading screen and
um if I happen to make assertions why
this loading screen is active normally
what
um what selenium will say hey um this
button that you try to click on is not
visible to me right now so right now if
I click here nothing will happen because
the button is not
there and um
therefore mostly all um so this is not
not a night night watch specific thing
um most uh yeah
most implementations for for selenium do
have such things um
um these are wait
for
States so I could say hey
um I know that when I go to this URL
there's some kind of loading overlay or
um some asynchronous stuff and I could
say hey um let's wait until this loading
overlay is not
present or not visible would be
another
thing so the the difference between
presence and visibility is basically uh
an element could be on the page so the
dumb note is on the page but it's on
display nonone or hidden between uh
after another element or something and
uh in that case case it wouldn't be
visible and if that dumb node simply
doesn't exist uh it isn't present
so let's try to figure out how that
loading
overlay if I just had watched the the
talk about service workers
yesterday
um yeah it's just this loading class on
the body um
so that was actually that's what that
was
correct let's check if that
works
nope so he expected a second parameter
on
that
I think this is It's a time
out okay yeah um that's not actually
what we wanted but it's uh it
illustrates the the um issue here
because now we're getting an error that
we timed out while waiting for the
element loading um to be present
and we expected it to become not visible
but it wasn't actually found
so we need to ensure
that this element with the selector
loading is not present after we go to
this website and wait for 5 seconds for
at most 5
Seconds okay here we
go element loading was not present after
uh 33 M seconds and then all the rest of
our assertions work
okay um that's a bit
tricky because um yes you can do
that but um maybe if you animate an
element in in the view and you say hey
wait for this element to be to become
visible it will be visible when it just
enters the view a little bit so
um I I know how angular is solving that
and I don't know if I I assume that
other animation Frameworks have another
approach so I think if you
have
um I guess jQuery can do that too that
you just manually inject the JavaScript
into the page that uh sets all
animations to zero so it just happened
instantaneously um that's the magic be
one of the testing magic behind angular
animate and I think other animation
Frameworks can support something similar
so the idea is that you just disable
animations for Inn
tests um what I just did in a case where
I um wasn't able to do that is uh work
with PES but that's not elegant so um uh
we checked what is the longest animation
that we can expect and then when there
was a state that we know here an
animation is happening here we just
waited for 500 milliseconds but I see
that this is not a good not a not an
elegant solution but it works for all in
our
case so question
problem um no sorry the question was if
if I had problems with scroll events um
not really I ran into problems when I
try to scroll in phantomjs because uh
that kind of don't support scroll events
but I haven't died into that so we just
didn't use Phantom Js then uh I think it
would be possible somehow but um we used
um Native browers so Firefox and Chrome
for the most part and there the
scrolling was uh we had no problems did
you have any problems concretely
or
okay okay so the problem was um with a
phantomjs yeah I can relate to that but
I haven't I don't have a good solution
for
that should we just continue with some
questions or there any um thing that you
want to see or have have five minutes
left or four actually um so more
questions
or are more questions do you have
another interesting thing you want to
show
us um I can show you the
um the visual regression stuff we did um
but as a disclaimer we didn't actually
test it so right now that's just a tool
that um produces screenshots and we are
in the process of using that screenshots
to to actually test that against another
state so basically it's just what you
just saw um we are going on a page like
this
and clicking around to to uh produce a
state that we want to test and then we
make a screenshot of that and the next
step would obviously be to have some
kind of image diffing tool to uh say hey
we have a change or we don't have a
change and um the big question that uh
is most of the parts not really solved
in my opinion is how to say how to to um
come up with a state that we want to
test against with so
um it's kind of easy to make a
screenshot of a page but how do what's
the state that we compare against so
[Music]
um um if if this runs in a Ci or I have
a p request test that makes automated
screenshots what is the state that we
want to achieve here um I do a put
request because I want to change
something
and when the the tool just said maybe uh
it fails because because it says Hey the
button that you just changed is now no
red instead of
green maybe that's exactly what I wanted
to have so the um big question is how
how do do we
um create the input for the test so what
what's the state
yeah look on the the game framework
where you can uh simply write how
to our component has to behave so when
we are in a break point with uh less
than 300 pixels then the has to
be no sorry I haven't so this this
framework would probably solve the
problems you have this okay so what's
what was the g
g galin yeah so um that was just a
comment about the galin framework and uh
I haven't had a looked at it but that
would May that may be uh an framework to
solve exactly the issue that I just said
and I have ideas on that and um would
like to talk about that but um these are
not in a presentable State I
think thank
you